let's uh let's talk a little bit about
the dark souls the third Dark Souls game
yourself and Mary Mary's currently on
the switch at the moma doing a great job
hit those buttons Mary yeah you gotta go
and you guys put up a bunch of Rico
videos on guys why are you today
gameplay sort of features about what's
in it and I don't add up to much into
the exactly what you guys talked about
there just give it a quick overview of
what you saw last week at the docks was
three events I'm why you're excited
about sure her Edmond trend and I Tran
and I from our Australia office we all
played the first three hours roughly we
had four hours but I think once you beat
the third boss that's pretty much three
hours they might change a few things
when the game releases in about a month
in the US a little more than a month but
it pretty much we got to see how you're
specifically traveling throughout the
world how you're leveling up how you're
making your weapons better how there's
no more hollowing if you're a Dark Souls
player you know what following is you
know you die your health starts
gradually going down until you can you
know become human again now there's like
embers and they pretty much when you die
you lose the flame the cinder something
whatever it's called I'd have to look
back at the article but and that's
essentially just once you beat a boss it
rekindles you and then you your health
goes back up or you can find these
embers in the world so that's going to
be one of the major mechanics the world
itself is actually pretty fragmented
each area is pretty like labyrinthian
it's very still much a lot to explore
and everything which is exciting because
that's you know those games are never
giving you too much direction yeah but
now there are areas you can't just get
to like an you might in an open world
you have to actually go to the to a
bonfire too fast travel in previous
games all right the bond personal
connectives right yeah they facilitated
fast travel now that they're necessary
as you travel you still go back to the
Firelink shrine I know a lot of people
didn't love the hub world and to for
them unfortunately its back same as
blood-borne that's kind of the way they
do in there right you have really yeah
going back to the hunters dream and then
used to go back out and up into the
overworld um yeah overall we got to pick
whatever class we wanted I went with
warrior just in the interest of beating
the third boss Mary went with the
sorcerer and add one would-be thief so
we got to try out a few different things
we have videos of all those three bosses
are really varying and you know scale
and like how you fight them first one
was just a tutorial kind of a night with
leaping attacks and a spear and whatnot
the next one Voort I think VOR dt I
don't know ye he's more of a like a
four-legged dashing you have to do a lot
of side dash and kind of stay between
his legs yes or like a weak spots Mary
yeah Mary has a nickname for him I it
just gates me right now but um yeah and
then the players lot of comments
gigantic um like this something rotted
tree or something and he he's so angry
molesting tree yeah he's so fat that he
can't really attack you he just falls on
you guys are like land all his weight on
you and there's specific bulbs on his
body or you have to keep hitting and
there it was just the three bosses I
thought we're all different in their own
way and doesn't have that like amazing
feeling when you meet bosses that it did
in Dark Souls 12 though or is this like
it's great that this series become so
popular but is it having that same
effect yeah it's still it's still pretty
difficult um I think the other people
the event were having much more trouble
with the third boss and I was but the
second boss one that took me a while i
think mary night that was our hang up
the third one I kill in the second try
but maybe that's because I was again the
Warriors much more damage so I was kind
of you know I had the advantage there
but uh ya know they I was still
exhilarating to kill them and then you
know you get you go back to Firelink
shrine and can you get new upgrades from
killing these bosses and whatnot and
yeah I'm uh I'm excited to see more I
can't really speak to the quality of
obviously the overall game yet but of
those first three or four hours i played
it's very it's looking promising so
we'll see what i see some gameplay here
which you guys recorded what are you
playing on what console that was on xbox
one this one guy we played on pc last
year when we had that preview of n right
that's good actually hear ya so oh yeah
it looks it looks it looks good at the
demo for sure was the pc version looking
noticeably
or was it cuz I drama with PC ports in
the past well the pc version i played
was back in august right or so so I I
don't know i'm sure it's made they've
made progress with it since then I
remember looking fine in August was it
locked at 30 frames for a second uh that
was the deal with the first two games
I'm musi oh right uh I don't know I
think our I don't know I have no back
our videos well we do have a video from
August 2015 they should just hire that
one guy we did all that lighting stuff
on it and so tell me about some of the
new stuff in it then as well I know the
the weapon arts as here in a today and
it's kind of like blood-borne esque
where the weapons kind of have alternate
uses yes or new like currency for this
or new like ammunition almost for this
um yeah so that's what another thing we
got to see they're called FP points okay
i'm not entirely sure what that stands
for I tried lunch figure yeah fruit
punch points it's the blue it's like a
mana bar um and the cool thing is you
know you have typical Estus flasks for
your health and then you have like the
FP flasks and when you go to the
blacksmith you can a lot more slots to
eat to one of the other you have four
total slots so I could just say I don't
use my weapon arts at all I'm just gonna
go for Estus flasks or you if you're a
sorcerer like Mary maybe be one to
consider this because she used the magic
she could just say you know I want one
Estus flask as a last resort but I'm
just gonna go three of the man of flasks
so it kind of is that risk reward thing
or just tailoring to your play style um
but yeah you kind of have to just manage
how much how many FP points you have
until the next bonfire until you kill
the next boss because once you're out
you can't use webinars mmm and each that
those played a big part it's dark souls
answer to blood-borne trick weapons you
know you'd like extend the saw blade or
turn the put the sword into the Kirk
hammer these ones you switch essentially
to like a two-handed grip and then you
know the battle axe is like this war cry
it is a damage buff or you know you can
kind of the long swords actually have
the specific attacks that might do more
damage to certain enemies with the you
know they take thrusting damage more
Slayer image spear and people that yeah
I think that's in
an assassin no that's a hell there's a
Harold Harold sorry get your axles yeah
terminology right bro so that's a Harold
I've not played yet we do have yeah we
have footage of all the weapon arts as
you're seeing al but yeah it's it it
definitely feels like a Dark Souls game
with blood-borne influent influences but
still its own separate entry which is
why I'm optimistic about it but again
what to see when we get the game don't
you had a month's time or so we are
actually gonna get the Japanese version
so we can play Turley oh right comes out
March 24th in Japan and then April 12
yeah everywhere else right so why that's
actually I didn't realize it was that
much of a distance between the two of
them yeah Wow week after GDC it's
probably a good idea that something we
got GDC cool awesome like my hearty
thank you so much and yeah if you're a
fan of Dark Souls do want to see more of
that stuff make sure to go to gamespot
com Mike and Mary put up a bunches of
sweet videos go check a man